welcome back to my channel my name is
samuel i'm amanda
and this is the samuel and amanda show
where we talk about money
marriage and life so firstly amanda
how have you been we've been up to my
week's been pretty good i've been
usual hanging with the kids enjoying the
sunshine the weather's like changed now
but
i feel like we've really made the most
of the weather and
i've just been yeah sort of doing lots
of kiddie things and
yeah anything working as well you know
we've been we've been moving some of our
properties to social housing yeah i've
been doing that as well
so managing reaper projects
and all kinds of stuff and i've been
running events this week so i've just
literally yesterday and today i've been
running the lease option bootcamp
we also when we film these sometimes
people might think you know do we film
lots of podcasts and then schedule them
out
or do we film it and then put it out um
you know schedule it for like the
saturday ahead or whatever
no but when you watch these chats it's
usually
minutes before we actually said it it's
very curious it's the closest thing to
live as you'll get because right now
it's saturday evening and it's probably
half past five so you should be watching
this about seven and onwards um
but the biggest question that amanda
gets asked
all the time is how
do you maintain your wiped teeth oh
wow actually i'm in the comments i
should have like a colgate sponsor or
something maybe i'm reading the comments
it's just like mine is teeth or white
amanda's teeth are white my mentor's
teeth are very oh my gosh i use colgate
to brush my teeth and i think maybe my
red lipstick helps them stand out a bit
more as well but yeah i just brush
also i'm doing today i'm doing this
thing this week where
no not this week this month yeah where
i'm only eating
vegetables fruit and meat so zero carbs
or
or anything like that and it's going
pretty well
i think you've done so well so far like
yeah i'm like four pounds down look at
me look how slim my face is looking
right now
getting this summer body ready i'm
getting my summer body ready but also i
just don't
i just don't want to be at the crash
courses because we're back at the crash
courses and i just don't want to be
you know barely hanging out on stage at
the crash courses so
i'm trying to get um in fact lockdown
officially
doesn't properly end until the end of
july yeah end of july now
they've been doing they need it haven't
they so what did you think of the
extension so annoying i think it
actually ends the day before my birthday
the 19th of july my birthday is the 20th
because apparently what happened was
amanda had a meeting with boris
and she was like look dude look dude if
you want to delay the lockdown that's
fine
that's fine but july 20th is my birthday
yeah and by then
nah nah nah so it lives on the 90s yeah
it lifts on the 19th but i mean we still
can do quite a lot of things at the
moment anyway yeah we can go out to eat
and stuff
i think his lockdown is officially not
lifted because i want to be honest i've
got back in shape by the end of lockdown
because that way
lockdown would have been so long i've
got in shape back out of shape and back
in shape baby lockdown
um okay cool so we've got the crash
courses coming up
exciting and i want to talk to you
amanda about from a behind-the-scenes
perspective
okay what is it like because you travel
with me
quite a lot um so firstly what's the
purpose of you coming to the crash
courses because you don't do much on
stage maybe a little
teeny barely anything you hate me
putting you
yeah i'm like oh my goodness i just want
to watch occasionally i pull her up on
stage
normally she sits in the audience and a
lot sometimes people don't know that
she's my wife and they'll be like it's a
great training day isn't it
fantastic and she's like yep i've seen
it a thousand times
in fact the content the content was
probably mostly created
but yeah i've seen it a thousand times i
should know it inside out but
what do you come i usually come just to
keep you company really just to sort of
keep you company in the evenings when
you just
at the end of the day by yourself i tell
you biggest secret okay biggest secret
is this
doing crash courses or just training in
general
can be very very
lonely and the reason it can be so
lonely is because
i remember like just before the lockdown
happened like 2019
i'll be an event hundreds of people
there and
lots of staff members crew members and
it's like
most people there are there to learn
about property but for me to just be
able to just chill
and just have a conversation like it's
you know
and if i'm away like this tour is going
to be a crash course in swindon and
portsmouth and
i just thought if i'm on my own i'm
going to be having to talk property
constant constant constant and even like
in the breaks or when in the evenings
i'll be having dinner
it's going to be people asking me about
property or
whatever so it's nice to be spice up his
uh his tour yeah to spice up my tour
and uh and and and be able to just you
know
when i go to bed just be able to just
have a little bit of normality so that's
cool and also
just generally you're amazing to be
around oh thank you i know ideas
we like traveling together and stuff so
i don't think that changes when it comes
to you working as well we just travel
together
yeah and we can bring the kids yeah um
and different things like that so
it's really really really good um in
other news
exciting news my book became an official
amazon bestseller today so
because previously it was it was best
seller in some categories like the
kindle version but it was loud it's
officially like it's got
you can see it says number one best
seller it's amazing you've done so
well with that like it's such an
achievement i mean writing a book in
itself is
like really really hard but to get it on
and then to get it number one bestseller
it just shows how much value's in there
so if you haven't
already downloaded copy ordered it then
i would highly
recommend number one i can even see that
best seller
so i'm really really really really
pleased about that that is incredible
that's like
yeah how many days has it hasn't even
been a week yet has it
nope it's been five days another secret
is
the secrets of property development i
wrote that book how long did it take me
to write the whole book
oh like this how long was it i don't
remember
but literally okay he didn't even tell
me about it you never even did
you were just kind of doing it and then
all of a sudden you're like oh i've
written this book and i was like
what you haven't even told me about it
yeah and you're just like oh i'm like
finished now one day just like what
one day yeah one day to write the book
oh there we go the light is better
hey yeah it took me took me one day to
write the book
um and one of the questions that we had
we didn't really have many questions
from from last
from last week so if you've got
questions for me and for amanda
anything at all just go ahead and ask
someone asked me if my dissertation that
i wrote about biblical economics and
being a a christian business person
whether
that is still around and it is
aspects locksmiths i basically
summarized the the whole thing and put
it into a book and the book
is this book which is my very first book
which is called do the possible watch
god do the impossible
um we've kind of wrote this together but
mandy didn't do too much but
it was just the inspiration
was it may do the possible watch the
impossible well
it's it's pretty obvious i think oh yeah
that's what you say when you don't know
self-explanatory you know if you don't
understand that then you're a [ __ ]
what do you mean you tell us what it
means author of the book
hello come on come on do the possible
watch god yeah
take one step and then like have faith
and then god will carry you through and
you know yeah i guess i think i think a
lot of people as well like when we go
you know we go to
like we start going to zambia and doing
talks and stuff
you know a lot of them are saying a lot
of people there they've not got much
money not much and they say oh
we're going to pray we're going to pray
that god will give us more money or god
will give us
and it's just like actually no you you
need to do the possible you do
everything you can do
um do the thing have the have the power
um
and then god will do the impossible um
so
you know that's kind of what it is but
this whole book is really about how
as a and it's not just for christians i
mean i wrote it initially for myself
it was my own it was like a study for
myself because i was grappling with the
whole
issue of being a good person and being a
christian and also
also being a businessman and trying to
make money and this is how they actually
the two go hand in hand as opposed to
conflict so yeah check it out it's on
amazon and this is just one of my
six books i think i'm going to reread
that because yeah
i haven't read it well i've read it when
you released it but i think it'd be a
good one to read again do you think you
should read it again so that you can
understand what the title means
whatever whatever i don't know if you
can hear if you apologize if you can
hear our kids
screaming in the background play
fighting
and going crazy all right about three
kids luke
ruby and jessica why do i
call jessica ruby and ruby jessica
i don't know they are very similar
they're the same
they're literally yeah we say they're
the same person if they were just like
born at the same time they would have
been like identical twins aged
scary i foreign it is i feel like yeah
they're gonna be like such bezzies
growing up because they seem so alike
already it'll be interesting to see what
jessica's
personality is gonna be like as she just
gets older you said
in a recent interview recent interview
with me okay well it was a podcast
discussion it feels like an interview
because i come up with all the content
you said you potentially wanted one more
kid yes i did
i did now after four months of having
a newborn and also you know the
the issues that come with
have i said too much no what i mean is
you know like
you tiny tiny tiny little bit of belly
fat oh my gosh
this like mum-tum thing okay
i mean i don't i can't even see it i'm
like what what
okay so i had a c-section and it was my
third c-section and this time around
just everything's just been much harder
usually like i just bounce back weight
wise
this time it's taking a while she's got
a little pretty slim to me
i've got a little bit well i'm not even
a little bit i've got mumtum but it's
still like a bit swirling as well and
stuff it's just like oh
but anyway i don't know has that
affected anything could you still want
four kids
i feel like for vanity reasons i'd
probably be like i don't want any more
just
because i don't want any more damage
done to my body but
i think just looking at the bigger
picture and a fourth child
would just bring sounds like she still
wants more she's like i don't care man
i'll have the mom time
whatever you know i'll have another kid
joy
it's just like amazing what kids but why
for if they bring that much to a 105
no because i think you know what kind of
car you're going to drive when you have
five food
a mom car i know no difference down that
route oh my goodness yeah
how do you enjoy your mum car mum cars
all right i mean i don't love it
we're going to do a tour at some point
we need to show off amanda's new car
which will be here in 2023 so we'll be
able to show you around
show you what an electric car looks like
um why did you say 2023 because that's
where murray put the order in
oh no no no no he's winding me up
there's just a delay it's just a delay
in the meantime she has a mom car what
she doesn't realize is that is the new
car
that is the new that's the case we'll be
swapping cars okay cool
all right let's see if we've got any
questions we didn't have too many
questions again put them in put them in
put them in
um how has your faith
helped you in your marriage and would
you have ever considered marrying
outside your faith
so i would have never considered
marrying outside of my faith just
because
i don't know i think it's just really
hard it's confusing for the kids as well
how would you bring up your kids
but you know not judging anyone who has
but i don't think i would have
um there's no right or wrong everybody's
different yeah you know i mean someone
got all annoyed actually in the comments
i can't see if i can find it but
someone's like how can you try and give
relationship advice it's like
oh really it's like well calm down like
we are literally just
good we are literally just sharing our
opinions
exactly our opinion on our if you
disagree that's cool if everyone was the
same it'd be boring
exactly um that's funny so how has your
faith helped you in your marriage
i don't know i just think it's faith
it's something that you take seriously
so when you get married you get married
in front of god and you make a covenant
you know so it's just
i don't know faith has helped because
i don't know would you rather me ask you
what the top of the book means
to answer i'm just trying to think
because i've never actually thought
about it it just does
just help see your questions i feel like
i take i take i take the marriage very
seriously it's not something that i take
lightly
and when how's that in fact would you
not anyway
well i don't know you don't know because
you get married in a church don't even
before god so
for me it's i just don't know i haven't
thought about it
i'll answer the question what do you
think of a proper answer oh my goodness
go on there okay
how would you find it in your marriage i
mean for me interestingly if it wasn't
for the fact that i had a faith in god
and was christian
i wouldn't be married to amanda and the
reason i wouldn't be married to another
few reasons number one is because
our culture differences amanda being
from a zimbabwean family her dad being
you know strict traditional african
zimbabwe and man
wasn't feeling as we've talked about
before her being with a white english
man
and i approached your dad and i said
look
um you know actually we're one brother
you know like we're one in christ and
ultimately and i think because your dad
is christian
it was almost the fact that he couldn't
really argue with like the comments no
we're separate and we were it's like no
i believe that we all come from one and
i believe that we're all
so i think i feel like yeah common
ground so i think
i think um you know you wouldn't have
even been allowed to marry me
if it wasn't for faith and i think that
for me faith is it's hard it is a hard
question to answer because it's kind of
like everything it's
it's really hard to imagine what it
would be like if we didn't have
the faith if i didn't have a faith
because it's just it's just how the way
that
i see everything is through my
perspective of my faith in god
um but would i consider marrying outside
of my faith
i personally can't see myself marrying
outside of amanda
so again it's like quite a hard one to
really even visualize
um but i don't know if you've got
anything else to add to that um
no i don't but i guess the only other
thing that i could say is that in
marriage obviously
you have ups and downs and stuff i guess
going back to the bible and being able
to
read through that to have it strengthen
us and stuff and show us how
people live there then i guess that
helps yep
uh i can just read the guy that was
having uh having a rant
no i won't even read it he's all right
you really have to
i'm gonna read the app all right someone
said um just a question when people
when people say things about samuel how
does amanda feel
and really yeah that's such a good
question of course she feels amazing
because they're saying amazing stuff
of course it's really nice things oh my
gosh when people say stuff about samuel
honestly i'm just like
why i order no i'm just like oh you're
obviously just not happy with yourself
and with your life and they're just a
hater i just think
they're just jealous and haters i
honestly don't really pay much attention
but i do
before i used to think oh it's so
annoying but to be honest
i don't even really focus on it it's
just like whatever but
it is annoying i think as well it's only
really
online because anyone else yeah no one's
ever
walked up to samuel and said i don't
like you because of this or so it's just
online so
you're greedy you're rich it just yeah
it's literally just a keyboard
warrior sir it's just online and online
the online world and the real world are
two very different places
true i think you need to you know need
to remember that yeah what do you reckon
yeah totally great and yeah do people
people ever say about you you don't ever
get any slack online
you only have wonderful comments yeah i
think yeah that's true
yeah that's true and if anyone does have
a message anything bad it's usually
about my husband so if you're thinking
of sending me a message about how bad my
husband is then just don't bother even
yeah okay cool uh last question is what
is it like
living together working together
raising kids together doing everything
together do we not just need our
own time like even though you were born
against that as well
you were warned against yeah i was
warned against that because i was like
do you want to come and work on the
business and everyone told her
yeah they were like oh my goodness but i
actually like it but
i mean we do have separate time like
sometimes we'll be in the house at the
same time but we're not like
literally like this with each other all
the time as much as i'd like to be
we're not like this all the time like we
do have our own space and we have our
own time and stuff but we actually
happen to really enjoy each other's
company as well which is quite nice we
happen to be bff with bffs like when we
got married i said it's like
being married to your best friend and
you're having like a constant sleep over
forever
and i just love it so it's awesome
that's sweet yeah it's funny are we
having to sleep over tonight
yeah yes so that is the end of
this week's podcast uh we're gonna shoot
if you want to comment below
questions thoughts suggestions anything
at all we will
do our best once next week thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]